Global stock prices and oil prices have
fallen as China Witnesses its most
severe civil unrest in decades Chinese
citizens have been demonstrating against
the country's strict strategy to contain
covid-19 cases which has taken a harsh
toll on lives but also on the country's
economy not since the pro-democracy
rallies of 1989 has the government in
Beijing faced such dissent from its own
people
the simmering anger of many people in
China is boiling over more now dare to
take to the streets the Foxconn workers
Uprising is transforming into a
nationwide protest
people can no longer stand the long and
frequent lockdowns Chinese citizens are
demanding relief from government rules
we can live a normal life only if they
ease the restrictions otherwise
everything will come to a halt
how many people have the savings to
support themselves if things stay this
way and even if you have money to stay
at home every day that's not true living
that's lingering on the last breath of
air
experts believe that the widespread
lockdowns endanger the country's
economic progress president Xi Jinping
and the Communist Party are currently
driving China's economy into the wall
warns British Economist George Magnus
the trouble in China of course is that
the Communist party is very rigid in its
view and very controlling in its
attitude to everything from industry to
the economy society and everything you
can think of so the problem if I want to
kind of encapsulate it really is that
China's development model on which the
legitimacy of the Communist party is
based at home and also to some degree in
the big wide world that development
model is is no longer fit for purpose
although many companies are still
earning a lot of money experts predict
that China is losing its luster as a
valuable partner in the global market
for companies to be able to to now kind
of look at other countries in Asia and
beyond for changing the supply chains
that have taken decades to to build up
it won't happen quickly but I'm pretty
sure it is starting to happen now it's
not just the impact of the lockdowns
there are other problems of China's own
making the real estate market which
makes up 30 percent of China's economic
output is in deep crisis the government
has put the brakes on the successful
Tech sector it has become too powerful
growth is slowing and international
investors are withdrawing the
government's goal of becoming the
world's largest economy is receding into
the distance
oh we can now speak to Marina rudyak who
is a China specialist at the University
of Heidelberg thanks a lot for joining
us on the program Marina and how much
are these economic considerations
playing a part in the discontent among
people in China at the moment
well as soon
role if you remember in summer there was
a real estate crisis people stopped
paying their mortgages because they were
afraid they will never get to see the
flats they are paying for there was a
crisis with access to bank accounts
where people were protesting in front of
banks saying no savings no human rights
but it is not the only reason why people
are protesting
but as the economy slows we also see
that that dream of China being the
largest economy in the world sort of
slipping away as well how much of
President XI jinping's ability to cling
on to power so far and keep extending
his terms has been down to the
performance of the economy
well if you remember and one of the you
know founding myths of the party was to
make the people richer and since thanks
Xiaoping uh the consensus with the
people was you know we make sure that
you are better off economically and you
stay out of politics
um and this seems no longer to work
certainly not for the younger generation
that was born after the 1980s and this
that is experiencing
um an economic downturn and the
limitation of their rights
this seems to be bubbling over though
with the protests against the zero covid
that seems to be sort of the focus of
the anger as it were um is there any
chance of this zero covid policy being
dropped though because of the processor
because of the economic impacts
well the party is is in a very difficult
situation on the one hand
China does not have enough intensive
care bad capacities the level of
vaccination is fairly low and the
effectiveness of Chinese vaccines is
also lower than the one of Western
vaccines on the other hand now with the
people protesting it's very clear that
the government will have trouble
continuing the policy as it is so I
think what we can expect is you know
selective responses to what the people
are asking for also to make sure to
separate the anti-covet protests
from the protest against you know the
governance and of the government
yeah I guess we have to see where these
protests go and how they develop don't
we Marina rudyak from the University of
Heidelberg thanks a lot for joining us
here on DW business
thank you